WHY THEY WERE HERE.
WE WERE BOTH
GETTING WHAT WE WANTED.
I GOT TO WORK THROUGH
MY NERVOUSNESS AROUND WOMEN--
SORRY, I'M KIND OF SHAKING.
- DON'T BE NERVOUS.
[laughs] DON'T BE NERVOUS,
THAT'S SO CUTE.
[laughs]
- AND THEY
GOT TO BE ON TV.
- I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE EVERYONE
INTRODUCED TO KANGEN WATER.
THIS WATER IS ONE OF
THE BEST WATERS OUT THERE.
IT HAS A PH OF 9.5.
- I'D NEVER BEEN
THAT GOOD OF A FLIRT,
BUT I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRACTICE WITH SO MANY
BEAUTIFUL GIRLS.
YOU HAVE BEAUTIFUL EYES
AND BEAUTIFUL LIPS,
AND LOVELY HAIR,
AND YOUR STYLE IS...
WONDERFUL.
- OH...THANKS, NATE.
[awkward laugh]
- SO TELL ME YOUR
DEEPEST, DARKEST SECRET.
- MY DEEPEST,
DARKEST SECRET IS...
I DON'T LIKE WEARING SOCKS.
- THAT'S GREAT.
BUT AS THE NIGHT PROGRESSED...
- OH, COOL.
- MAGIC.
MY FLIRTING SKILLS
DRASTICALLY IMPROVED.
- DO YOU RIDE MOTORCYCLES?
I MEAN--
- I DON'T RIDE A MOTORCYCLE,
BUT I AM A BIT OF A BAD BOY.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED NEXT
I WOULD HAVE NEVER EXPECTED.